and freddie peralta ready to go to work
tonight partner yeah he's been terrific
25 appearances so far this year one
complete game you see that record at
nine and four 257 his earned red average
edmond chases one big swing and a miss
down he goes
and freddie peralta starts this night
with a strikeout he had nine punch-outs
no walks his last time matt against
detroit there's peralta deals and a
swing adamus
back-to-back case to start the night and
that fastball is jumping straight away
in a 3-2 pitch
base hit into center tyler o'neill
edmond goldie o'neil arenado
since september 8th they alone averaging
about four runs a game and nolan hits it
a ton and a deep left it is gone
two nothing cardinals
rbi's number 100 and 101
and he does it in style
2-zip st louis
the first since matt holliday
with a hundred or more driven in so john
lester
i think this surprised many of us but
apparently not the cardinals this was
always in their plan to have him stay on
every fifth day in pitch
and letting the defense go to work like
this
three up and three down
happening in the books and st louis on
top two nothing just uh from a spiritual
standpoint a motivation standpoint so
what you're saying is he's kind of an
mvp guy i believe
there's a swing out of this that mundo
sosa strikes out how's that curveball he
talked about that when he came on the
air it was a big pitch for
freddie
knew he wasn't going to pitch deep into
that one and boehner hits it down the
left field line it is
in the corner and fair
harrison bader who had a key
two run double yesterday
as a one-out double here
trade deadline acquisitions right off
the end of the bat that'll work like a
bun
and peralta makes a play for out number
two
vader the third
[Applause]
harrison bader the runner at third two
outs in the second
and he got him struck him out
not exactly where he wanted it but
effective enough and it gets a k
four k's for peralta two nothing red
birds here come the brewers
lester with a one two three inning all
three outs in the air garcia hammers one
center field
bader looks up and she's gone
avi garcia
welcome back to the lineup number 28
brewers on the board in the second
inning on a frozen rope off the batter's
eye in center field maria's figures to
be in the starting lineup against all
left-handers
and he sends that one deep into left
center field
wasting no time against john lester
see what he has in mind here one ball
two strikes
got
him peralta strikes out
nolan arnotto on the slider
three up three down inning after the
brewers scored a pair in the second 2-2
game
when he's right the lefty is really good
we'll see how that plays out
two and two the count
and a strikeout
the first for john lester
who by the way is trying to pick up win
number 200 here tonight and david
stearns made a trade with tampa for
willie adamus
fly ball into center that'll stay in the
ballpark backing up
bader and he makes the catch
one-two pitch and away venomous peralta
strikes out yada yada molina
second out of the inning
on the ground to short adamus fires the
easy way to wong and that will retire
the cardinals in the forum by doing the
same exact thing you have to be able to
adapt and we've seen that with john more
contact less swing and miss stuff still
effective
2-2 on the ground
tommy edmond
and a one two three for lester he'll
lead it off when we come back lester
edmund goldie do up this earned run
average would be good enough for
fifth in the national league
if he qualified and he puts lester away
little foul tip into the mitt of manny
pina there is out
number one got the slider
as fast as 83.
and that one
a breaking ball popped up goldsmith
jammed himself and escobar makes a play
curveball slider to get him
one two three inning for freddie peralta
i always do a four scene that just had
run and he taught me that and it it
helped me so much
the strikeout number two tonight for
john lester
and we move to the sixth part of the
lineup coming up tied at two shot here
molina has grounded into a fielder's
choice and struck out over two tonight
bouncer through the whole left side here
comes o'neil
yelich his throw
not in time and the cardinals have the
lead on a yada year molina
single to left
and it's 3-2 st louis
2-2 now on sosa
and a call strike three he got him with
a change-up
sosa
asking john lipka for an explanation
that was right at the bottom of the
strike zone
see what he does 2-2 now and a swing out
of this he got one up there that time
peralta with the high cheese vader
strikes out
minimizing the damage for freddie
peralta the first two have been retired
here in the whole map of the sixth
in the air left center there's bader
john lester through six
and if the cardinals can hold on it will
be win number 200 in his outstanding
career
carpenter the other way and a base hit
yelidge cuts it off cripender thinking
two on his way to second
in there with a head first slide get him
on get him over now goldie is tasked to
get him in
and a high fly ball into left center
jackie bradley jr
with the momentum behind him makes the
catch here comes carpenter throw to the
plate is not in time
and goldsmith has made it a 4-2 st louis
lead
rbi opportunity for yadier molina
and yadi
drives in another here comes aronado
molina has driven in two tonight and
it's a five to st louis lee so garcia
gets the ninth inning for st louis
ground ball right side goldie there a
flip nine in a row for st louis and win
number 200 in the career of john lester
you